Bueno, hoy ha salido la señora Úrsula thunderline
no a presentar
los presupuestos de la ue
y los planes económicos de la ue,
y ha salido cachondeándose de la gente,
pero con estas palabras,
porque se estaba riendo.
O sea, si
mientras presentaba los planes europeos
y presentaba los presupuestos
se estaba riendo a carcajada batiente,
¿no? Y habla, pues,
de que hay que tener
todos tenemos que apretarnos el cinturón,
sacrificios no sé qué, no sé cuánto,
pero que a Ella no le van a afectar ni a ni ni ni
ni a los Amos del cortijo de toda la vida
le van a afectar, ¿no?
Entonces pues ya está,
es decir, cuando se toman medidas
que lo que van en realidad
es en contra de los intereses de la gente,
pues entonces ocurre eso, es decir, ya está.
La interés es que la gente sea cada vez más pobre
y la gente cada vez es más pobre.
Yo ya se lo dije
hace 1 año hay 1 interés para que la gente sea sí,
ya se lo dije hace 1 año. Interés